so kind I think I know why you're happy
tonight because Thank You Vic I will be
taking marriage offers after the show
not here during the show but three
Republicans found a little backbone this
week and there
to be we are going to have an
investigation of Brett Kavanaugh who's
up at the Supreme Court as you know and
the investigation by the FBI is gonna
last one week so put that on your
[ __ ] calendar Brett write everything
down and you know this is the two ladies
in the Senate the Republicans and jeff
flake of Arizona I couldn't believe Jeff
Flake and part of they said maybe did
you see this maybe he was turning around
because he was confronted when he was
getting on the elevator they did watch a
little bit of that video by somebody who
had the guts
I've been seeing a guy take it in the
elevator like that since Beyonce sister
kicked jay-z
oh and then they tried cornering Lindsay
Graham but he but he got away because
he's familiar with the back door
[Applause]
but come on Republicans up a lot of
trouble with women that's a sausage
party and the Republican Party they
don't so you know what they did they
hired a female prosecutor to ask the
questions to Professor Ford it's like
when a mobster thinks there's a bomb
under his car he makes his wife started
you go out there do it but you know her
testimony when someone's being real it
shows it reads even conservatives had to
admit it was compelling and credible it
was so compelling and so credible during
it Brett Kavanaugh tried to turn up the
music
that
[Applause]
but this was a very different Brett
Kavanaugh he came out swinging like his
penis at a college party that's well
there's a sexy this stuff happened so
fast in this last week we remembered at
the beginning that we had a second
accuser also rather credible who said
this was at Yale he was at a party there
and said she was drunk and he dropped
his pants in front of her and exposed
himself
I mean imagine open your eyes and seeing
that dick and then he pulls out his
penis
[Applause]
this was a totally different Brett
Kavanaugh than the one who we saw
testifying like a week before totally
different angry the volatile bitter
belligerent because nothing says I'm not
capable of violent assault like flying
into an unhinged rage always a good
strategy know that Supreme Court will
now be eight bookish law nerds and the
Hulk but no really if that was a divorce
hearing she would have gotten the kids
that's how I
why did Cavanaugh suddenly act that way
cuz Trump told him to because Trump
didn't like that he was being meek and
you know good bread he likes bad bread
he wants someone in his image so he gave
him whiny little [ __ ] lessons
and you know what we have the evidence
is yearbook and everything this choirboy
at Kavanagh's well you know I spent my
high school years concentrating on my my
friendships in church church you know
what defense doesn't work so great
anymore I can't be a sex criminal I'm a
Catholic
like saying I couldn't have met Russians
I was at Trump Tower oh yeah he's going
on about who he has many friendships
with women he's helped many women and
supported them and helped them with
their careers you know and he also says
he's a big supporter of me too in fact
when someone is ordering drinks he
always says give me two because I don't
know if we could say he's definitely a
rapist I think that's too far but he is
the [ __ ] lawyer in a drunk
definitely a drunk maybe not now but
even in this testimony he mentioned beer
a lot I like beer do you like beer I
just finish a beer do you have any
[Applause]
I thought he was gonna write out on a
Clydesdale half of his yearbook entries
for about drinking getting shit-faced II
he's in keg and Ralph's club and if he
gets on the court skipped the Rope give
him a toga this guy is but he might not
he might not get on that's at least the
glimmer of hope we have
for one week you can look your kids in
the eye and say America is not a country
that puts a predator on the Supreme
Court in the White House short but not
disappoint